a legendary basketball coach is retiring
today moving back to las vegas
john treach is in studio with what this
could mean for the running rebels john
yeah everyone wants to leave a
professional legacy long cougar wants to
join his
in las vegas krueger is retiring after
35 years as a head coach the last 10
spent at the university of oklahoma the
68 year old is moving back to the desert
to help his son kevin
as lon is finishing his career 37 year
old kevin krueger
is just beginning kevin accepted the
unlv position on sunday
long spent seven seasons in the same
role from 2004 to 2011 and took the
running rebels to the tournament
four times unlv hasn't come close to
that success since
long left for norman on is expected to
assist kevin in the program building
process as a special assistant to his
son and
he also gets to be around his
granddaughter in 12 months of golf
long krueger won 674 games and took
five different programs to the ncaa
tournament perhaps the greatest
testimony to his impact is what happened
to unlv
after he left on april first twenty
eleven the running rebels are on their
sixth different
coach and lon is the only coach in three
decades
to win an ncaa tournament game